let's unpack the concept of Federated
learning a method for training AI models
that is all about keeping your sensitive
data right where it should be with you
now ai applications like chat Bots
recommendation systems and spam filters
they're all very data hungry and they
have been fed tons of examples
mountains of information which they use
to learn their specific tasks to build
an AI model
now normally in machine learning We
Gather all of this data from different
sources and bring it to one place all of
this will reside
in a central server and that's where the
actual training of the model takes place
Federated learning turns this process on
its head instead of bringing the data to
the model we take the model to the data
so here's how it works think every
device like a smartphone or a laptop or
a server it has its own local version of
a model
so each of these are reporting into
their own model and this model learns
from the data right there on the device
itself now after the model has learned
from the local data it sends only the
model updates back to the central server
not the actual raw data so this all goes
here
to the central server and then that
server Aggregates all of these updates
from all the devices to create what is
called the global
model
now why bother with this level of
decentralization well this concept was
first introduced by Google in 2016 at a
time when Global attention was focused
on the use and misuse of personal data
concerns about data privacy and security
prompted the search for alternatives to
traditional centralized AI training
methods giving birth to Federated
learning so let's imagine a scenario
involving a group of companies that want
to collaborate on building a model to
predict market trends but each company
has sensitive sales data they want to
keep private so each company has access
to an initial Baseline predictive Global
model here's our Global model up here
and this resides in a central
server
now in their individual environments
each company trains the instances of the
model using their own sensitive sales
data so we have the global model here
and then these individual models with
each company and here is their sensitive
sales data along the bottom and they're
tweaking and refining their model based
on their unique data so the companies do
not share their sensitive sales data
instead they only share the updates they
made to the model now these updates they
don't contain any raw sales data but
they do reflect the insights gained from
the data the model updates are then sent
back
to the central server
and here they're integrated into the
global model now this iterative process
continues with each company refining the
model based on their private data and
sharing only the model updates over time
this model becomes increasingly accurate
at predicting market trends even though
no company had to share their sensitive
data each Company benefits from the
collective intelligence of the group
while maintaining their data privacy
that is the essence of Federated
learning allowing for Collaborative
Learning from shared model updates while
keeping the actual data distributed and
private
now we can think of Federated learning
as coming in three flavors so there's
horizontal and horizontal Federated
learning describes the forecasting model
example we've just discussed where the
data sets were all similar in this case
the similarity was this was all sales
data
now another one is
called
vertical Federated learning so instead
of using similar data sets we're dealing
with complementary data using movie and
book reviews for example to predict
someone's music preferences
and then the Third Kind is called
Federated
transfer learning here we start with a
model that's already been trained to do
one task and then adapt it to do
something slightly different like like
how a pre-trained foundation model
designed to perform a task like
detecting cars is trained on another
data set to do something else entirely
like identify cats now the use cases for
Federated learning are far-reaching and
impactful just consider the healthcare
industry where Federated learning allows
medical institutions to collaboratively
train their models on their sensitive
data without sharing the actual medical
records or how financial institutions
can improve their fraud detection
mechanisms and credit scoring systems
without compromising on customer privacy
however Federated learning is not
without its challenges there is the risk
of inference attacks where adversaries
may try to extract information about the
data from the shared model updates when
we put them up there now to counter this
researchers are looking into strategies
like secure multi-party computation to
ensure privacy by encrypting model
updates or by adding a degree of noise
to the data to mislead potential
attackers other challenges include
computational efficiency because we do
have all of this work going on locally
here and maintaining transparency in
model training and creating incentives
for truthful participation look in the
end Federated learning offers a
promising path towards a new generation
of AI applications by addressing privacy
concerns and leveraging the power of
distributed computing
Federated learning holds the potential
to revolutionize how AI models are
trained
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like And subscribe thanks for watching